RICHARD BRANSON: When
we found this beautiful island,
I really hoped that one day,
I'd be able to work hard
and afford to come
and live here.
And then, finally, I thought,
"Okay, let's go and...
let's go and live
on Necker," and...
And not to retire,
on Necker,
because I think I've maybe
worked even harder since then.
You can hear
the lemurs.
Yeah, calling
in the background.
Which is, they...
Yeah, it's a lovely sound
early in the morning.
(LEMURS CALLING)
Hello.
You're looking very wet.
(CHUCKLES)
Most of the animals we've got on
this island, we've reintroduced.
So, you know, there
used to be scarlet ibis,
there used to be flamingos,
there used to be
giant tortoises.
They were killed off,
we've reintroduced them.
Giant iguanas, the same.
And then there are some
species, like the lemur,
that, you know,
weren't in this area,
but we're really
delighted to have.
They just eat
vegetables or leaves,
so there's no downside
effect to having them here.
(CHUCKLES)
These two make love
every morning.
The male one just says,
all the time,
"What a guy,
what a guy, what a guy,"
throughout the whole thing.
And then, when he
finishes making love,
he just goes...
(WHISTLES SHARPLY)
(CHUCKLING)
...and it's just, every time.
SPEAKER:
Where did they get that from?
I promise you,
it wasn't me.
(CHUCKLING)
I don't know who it was from.